so exactly why was quarantine imposed on
france so
suddenly well on thursday france
reported 2669
new infections in just 24 hours
that's the highest daily increase in the
country since its lockdown was lifted in
may
by comparison the uk has recorded around
1 000 infections a day
during the last week across france there
are regional differences levels of
infection
are higher in the capital paris
and its surrounding areas but also here
on the south coast
which is one of the most popular
destinations for tourists
here's how the uk was affected by the
pandemic a sharp
rise in cases leading to the peak in
april
and then declining gradually this is
where we are now
the office for national statistics says
infections are leveling off
although we know infections have risen
slightly today
and this is how the situation in france
compares to what is happening
in the uk you can see here that the two
lines follow a broadly similar pattern
but look at where they are now this
sharp increase
and now let's look at the infections in
spain it has one of the worst
coronavirus infection rates in western
europe
you can see here the infection rate
spiking and it was at the end
of july that the government imposed a
quarantine rule
on holiday makers returning to the uk
you can see a slight dip in the
infection rate
in the past few days but further
restrictions have been announced
including a ban on smoking in all public
places
and late night drinking in bars malta
and the netherlands have also been added
to the quarantine list and infections
there
are spiking faster than france the
question is
will the uk follow the same trajectory
as some of our european neighbors like
france
now they're seeing more regional more
nationwide
increases and that's what we might get
in this country we may follow the same
path we've had smaller localized
outbreaks and we've had one regional
outbreak where we've gone we've got a
restrictions in place from east
lancashire all the way through greater
manchester
and into parts of west yorkshire so
there is precedence in this country for
it happening here as well
it must be remembered that these are new
infections
and not deaths localized flare-ups were
expected
with lockdown easing we can say we are
now in a
different phase of the pandemic and
governments across
europe will be watching and reacting to
the rising
infection rates very closely